modern Orthodontics May and actually it
does sometimes retract the face it
causes a downswing in facial form if
that's happening then you're going to
increase the chance of sleep apnea which
means you could potentially make someone
live less alone and then you've got the
fact they're going to be less attractive
now you've gone along to an orthodontist
he's not warned you about these possible
side effects it's an elective procedure
that you didn't need to have done just
talking about the subject is just
stirring up The Hornet's Nest and you
know people will hate me just for
mentioning this now
all I'm saying is we need open debate on
this